en vista el nuevo confinamiento en la
ciudad estos parisinos intentaron huir
provocando atascos de 400 kilómetros
mientras otros lo intentaron por tren
los habitantes corrieron a las tiendas
antes de que cerraran todos los negocios
no esenciales durante las siguientes
semanas a pesar de que las peluquerías y
librerías permanecerán abiertas como
parte de una serie de medidas que
entraron en vigor la madrugada de este
sábado para salir de casa se tendrá que
diligenciar un formulario de permiso el
ejercicio al aire libre se permitirá en
un radio de 10 kilómetros desde casa y
por un tiempo limitado hasta el toque de
queda de las 7 de la tarde los viajes
fuera de la zona confinada están
prohibidos
excepto por urgencias o negocios las
medidas afectan a 16 departamentos en
francia- alrededor de un tercio de la
población están pensadas para frenar los
contagios que han aumentado un 19% esta
semana y el número de pacientes en
cuidados intensivos ha subido de 3500 a
4200 en las últimas 2
tengo que rechazar a 20 personas por
falta de espacio esto es un alivio
porque reducirá la presión el gobierno
culpa la variante británica responsable
de muchos nuevos casos el presidente
manuel macrón intentó evitar una crisis
política y económica derivada de las
nuevas restricciones e insistió en que
las nuevas medidas no son un
confinamiento pero hay pocas
restricciones extra que ayuden a evitar
la expansión del virus